I personally I'm just a student I'm a 20
year old student I'm doing engineering
and I came in to study I guess
as with the idea that I want to build
products that you know have an impact on
people that change people's perspective
of things and apps that help people when
our day to day basis I want the mindset
of the University which is getting exams
done getting results done so how do I
don't how do I stop myself for getting
more alive in a day to day basis well
this change happens with you know a
future so I make this distinction
between joy and happiness happiness
comes when you win the game when you get
an A in your exam happiness comes when
your number comes up in the lottery and
then it goes away you know that feeling
joy is something more underlying and you
the u.s. how do I have happiness on a
day to day basis you don't the things
that you will do you will not
necessarily enjoy but the question is do
you have a sense that they're a part of
something bigger that's where the that's
where the the value and the joy comes
from you don't have to like every day
but you do get to love every day you
don't like your children every day but
you love your children every day
right and I think we have this we've
created this unrealistic expectation
that every day at work has to be amazing
like every day of your relationship has
to be amazing and every day and your
friendship has to be amazing
it's it's just not it's an unfair
standard to put on a human being that's
an unfair standard to put on an
organization and sometimes it's us
sometimes the organization is trying so
hard but we have a narrative in our head
that we can't let go of that it's us
that's creating the unhappiness every
day we make ourselves victims and
everything you see you'll find there all
the evidence well we can choose to
change our narrative you know I have a
friend who moved to from a liberal city
to a very conservative state city in the
United States and she was very worried
and I said to her it's the most
wonderful opportunity in the world she
says but I'm gonna hate all these people
I said or you can learn to listen
understand what their motivations are
and understand what what they care about
and I bet you'll discover that your
values are the same as theirs
right some of its narrative some of its
perspective don't seek happiness the
happiness will happen here and there its
seek joy and that comes from
relationships and belonging and cause
[Music]